orwell warned us that there's no swifter
route to the corruption of thought than
through the corruption of language
now he might as well have been talking
about the biden white house and their
media pals
now let us explain
what happened at mar-a-lago was
rightfully described as a raid
but to former fbi honcho frankfigaloozi
oh that can't say that
keep your eye on the banner at the
bottom of the screen
agents by the way don't like the word
raid they don't like it the word raid
they don't like it they want to say they
executed a search warrant all of that
going on meticulous searching um even
you know i i've seen situations where
devices electronic devices thumb drives
are being searched for and they actually
have dogs
they made that raid banner disappeared
pretty quickly didn't they and their lap
dogs they quickly got the message
it's all legal it's all lawful it's not
a raid there wasn't a raid on his house
no doors were kicked down and trump
talks about a raid on his home no man
there was no raid on your home
oh really they were all invited in let's
have coffee but this isn't just an
isolated incident think of their
inability to define
woman
or how they pervert language about the
economy the last 10 times this nation
saw two quarters of negative growth it
was described as a recession but this
white house had other thoughts
in terms of the technical definition
it's not a recession that is not the
actual definition of a recession i would
really object to this kind of semantic
claim
and now they've moved on to inflation
readings the real inflation measure the
one felt by americans at the grocery
store gas pump is 8.5 percent
but according to biden
i just want to say a number
zero
today we received news that our economy
had zero percent inflation
in the month of july
zero percent
zero common sense and of course the
press they just echo it
inflation drops to zero in july
due to falling gas prices inflation
drops to zero democrats might just be
able might just be able to be like you
know what uh it has been bad for a while
with inflation but we're on the right
track now
it's actually a zero percent increase
since last month inflation is still at
its highest level in decades and the
administration is trying the same tricks
with wages
they've declined three percent in july
but from from a year ago but kjp and ron
clayne want you to think that americans
are making more money joining me now is
larry kudlow host of cuddle on fox
business
larry
it is orwellian the manipulation of
language
uh when real people are suffering with
food prices up ten point what is it nine
percent year over year but they keep
trying the same tricks
yeah food prices up fourteen percent
last three months so okay july was flat
because they got lower gasoline prices
uh june was up 17
and um may was up 12
so if all those mean zero inflation i
don't know you're gonna have to redefine
it if we're declaring victory with eight
and a half percent inflation i don't
really want to go there um it's beyond
orwellian but look they denied there was
a recession with two straight quarters
of gdp decline and the latest one laura
is really the inflation reduction act
right except that major economic models
from the government and the private
sector said wait a minute there is no
inflation reduction uh or we're not
taxing people under 400 000 a year but
in fact we learn as we dig into the tax
increases they are going to hit people
not only under 400 000 but under two
hundred thousand so this crowd is kind
of making a career out of shall we say
cognitive dissonance or fraudulent
statements
larry this new poll to your point out
from the economist
shows that people are agreeing saying
that 40 of americans think the climate
and energy bill will increase inflation
only 13 percent
say it'll decrease it
so the language manipulation that they
think works in the end people have the
lives they have right larry i mean
they're either doing better and they
know they're doing better or they're not
doing better they're getting poorer and
they know right now they're getting
poorer month to month to month in this
administration period
yeah yes well grocery prices go up as
you said uh gas prices cut a break but
they've been going up for 18 months or
16 months
real wages have been falling i mean they
know they're making more but it's buying
less which is probably the best
definition of inflation it means your
dollars are worth less so they just know
i mean they don't need biden to tell
them or his economist they know with
their own eyes and their own kitchen
table discussions and what they have to
deal with at the gas station and the
grocery store look at the other ones the
irs let's look at this irs story i mean
you've been talking a lot as we all have
about the outrageous uh break-in at
mar-a-lago okay the irs is making one of
the greatest power grabs i have ever
seen in governmental history with 87 000
new agents the burden of that according
to the government's uh economist will
fall on people making under two hundred
thousand dollars a year not rich people
as chuck schumer said today it's going
to call middle class and lower income
people now laura talk about a power grab
from the deep state did you see this
story it's on the fox business website
they're advertising job postings on the
internet okay
legally allowed to carry a firearm major
duties include carrying a firearm and be
willing to use deadly force if necessary
and be willing and able to participate
in arrests execution of search warrants
and other dangerous assignments these
are the irs agents they're supposed to
be tax accountants looking at your tax
returns and that's bad enough these guys
deadly force i love this you gotta look
at this story and report on it it just
goes to show you more
lies more fraud the irs is not going
after tax cheats they're going after
middle income people and small
businesses this is insanity
and larry maybe we should send all the
irs agents down to the border finally
get that thing all squared away with
that firepower
larry thank you for alerting me to the
great fox business piece we're all over
it thank you so much and thank you for
staying up with us tonight it's uh it's
late for larry sometimes he works all
the time hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else